whether a lush mountainous region in
southern Germany or an open pit coal
mine in North rhine-westphalia or the
RAB seed oil fields in northern Germany
these are pictures that you won't see
often they were taken by photographer
and her Kurtzman he's best known for his
documentary films but deutsche welle
commissioned him to shoot drone videos
all over Germany myosins canny front
when I can't capture the true beauty of
a landscape from the ground because I
don't have the proper perspective I
don't have to fly very high maybe just a
few meters just over the treetops that's
where i find that perspective i want a
feeling dizzy perspectiva be calm today
Kurtzman will be filming the monument
that commemorates Napoleon's defeat at
the battle of leipzig in 1813 it's
cloudy today but he managed to get some
good shots still decent weather
conditions are essential for any
successful airborne photo shoot
mazzoni on vient de ellas not really
it's easy to shoot when the sun's out
and there's no wind but you've got to
know how to fly when it's windy Starks
and gusty winds are upon my machine I
can handle wind speeds of up to 80
kilometers an hour depending on the
landscape anything more than that even
retrieving the drone starts to get
tricky dicky yes think of a hop locked
on selectably the drone is now cruising
over the rooftops of leipzig Gutzman
steers the craft over the city's park he
can follow the flight on his display
screen the batteries will last for only
15 minutes so he has to work fast but
before every flight gets one has to get
written permission from each German
state where he wants to fly he also has
to get permission from private citizens
to fly over their property but he says
the effort is worth it a fire in a
onesie like your and half times oh he
cooked I was around Lake Constance
recently and it reminded me what a
wonderful Christian Barack region it is
every other town seems to have a huge
monastery as working Poisson there's so
much history there I thought I knew the
region pretty well but I was quite
amazed by what I saw from me bullish
doctors candying I guess they're good
they are stuntman hi Nabila esna is
another photographer who works with
drones he specializes in shots of
statues and sculptures taken at eye
level so you can view them from a brand
new angle for some people drones are
just another high-tech toy this is a
drone competition in Berlin
but anti guttsman prefers to focus on
the aesthetic aspects of drone flight he
particularly likes shooting farming and
industrial areas like this pot ash mine
in the state of Lower Saxony is flieger
anh quan for asking i fly the drone over
a corn field during the harvest you can
see the furrows if I shoot straight down
from a normal perspective sometimes I
see graphic structures that remind me of
certain paintings hey none and you can
see more of undergirds man's drawing
photography on DWS travel website